[Applause]
happy friendly friday everyone we are so
happy you're here with us as you might
not know already we're number one in
late night tv again
beating
everyone from colbert to brian williams
and we did it faster than it takes a
bite and fart to clear an elevator
we never thought it would happen so
quickly or we would have created a
deadpool the competitors are dropping
faster than runners in a 90 and over
marathon
so this show's number one thanks to our
audience our amazing yes
all right that's it
that's enough for you our great panel a
host with so much sex appeal it should
be outlawed
but also our guests
like tonight's bret bear
the bread bear who makes m m look like
vanilla ice
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
i don't mean
[Music]
that went on for five hours
but that suit is the opposite of a
rapper's delight but it was definitely
better than the time stuart varney
collaborated with ghostface killa on
their number one hit wear my cheddah at
[ __ ]
but it's bread bear
did you know he has his own doll
sometimes i need the hard news of the
day but other times i just want to
cuddle why can't i have both
well now you can with the new bret bear
he's fair and balanced and unafraid to
snuggle
just squeeze his tummy and get informed
the 41st president
wants to go to maine this summer bret
bear is there when you start your day
french president emmanuel macron and his
wife arrived yesterday attended a dinner
at mount vernon and he's there at the
end of your day too when i get home at
night i just want something to hold that
brings me comfort but i also want the
news
at this hour voters are still casting
ballots in arizona's special election
thanks bret bear so get your bret bear
today
so
i own three of them
the fur helps dry my tears now brett
hosts the show special report which is
much better than the original title
which was barely legal
it's about as far from this show as you
can get
special report is caviar we're pork and
beans if special report is a bottle of
champagne then we're a six-pack of zima
yet we still have him on but will he
have us on his show i think we have a
better shot of getting invited on
reliable sources with captain fat pants
more important will he have cat on we've
made it no secret she wants to be on
special report i mean she burned this
message
[Laughter]
she learned how to do that from one of
her cellmates but as of yet no invite
special report has been as quiet as the
president when his doctor asks him where
he is
sure cat is more baggage than the lost
and found at laguardia but contrary to
what you've heard she does bathe
it's the third tuesday of every month
she brushes her teeth sometimes with a
brush sometimes with a piece of leftover
pizza crust but give her a few blasts of
febreze and she's good to go but we get
it brett's show is very serious and you
need to prove yourself the same way you
do if you want to be my masseuse
the obstacle course is insane
so maybe it's time kat shows that she
has what it takes to be on special
report
here's why i would make a great guest
for special report
i went to college and graduated with an
english degree just like you brett wow
we have so much in common it's almost
kind of creepy we work at the same
company and much like you i'm an
inspiration and a mentor to many of the
network's upcoming stars
[Laughter]
i know how to make eye contact
communicate and even laugh at jokes that
fall flat
i have a lot of experience from gutfeld
it doesn't exist it's the same thing
papa joe said in the about the deuce in
his pants
all right that's going too far
but
that's too much for you yeah and that's
how you know it's bad yes but don't just
take my word for it here are some
respectable people who agree with me
honestly brett i can't think of anyone
who'd be a better addition to your panel
than cat
please just let her be on she's emailing
me at all hours of the day i have not
slept through the night she even showed
up my house and you know all the fans
want to see me on special report right
guys
so in conclusion if i'm on special
report it won't be a problem i'll stay
out of everyone's way i won't eat a lot
of food i'll provide my own clothes and
even chip in for gas so book cat on
special report and give america the 6 pm
eastern it deserves
a special report not even funny you know
last time i watched it i didn't laugh
once okay and i don't get what is so
hard about brett's job anyway right he
just says what happened
you know it's not like he has his boss
on set with him all the time telling him
he's an alcoholic drug addict with the
failing marriage oh why is that light
still on why's it on i said cut i said
cut no cut cut cut cut cut cut
well kat that uh
that didn't end so well uh just keep
going with the monologue okay i will to
the monologue good news on the covid
front in austria a brothel promises 30
minutes of vip treatment in a sauna with
the sex worker of your choice in
exchange for the customer getting the
vaccine not included all the shots
you'll need after
meanwhile over here all we get is a
juice box and graham crackers no happy
ending there
but the point is this this is what you
see when you're on a war footing and
everyone wants to reward the troops and
we are the troops instead of shooting
though we get the shots which makes it
tough to see when this is going to end
even the new york times is asking if
it's time to start moving back to
normalcy as they say covet now presents
the sort of risk to most vaccinated
people that we unthinkingly accept in
other parts of life like driving or
swimming or eating at arby's but there
isn't going to be a day when we wake up
to headlines proclaiming that kovid is
defeated but that's the thing about war
it needs an ending or it won't end
here's a question what do the pandemic
afghanistan and the drug crisis have in
common they are all seen through the war
filter we have a war on drugs we had a
war in afghanistan and of course a war
is being waged against a virus and they
all show us that unless you have a
declaration of surrender from the other
side we never declare victory it can
keep going on forever even though to
everyone it feels like it's over just
like the daily show
we are really bad at stopping wars
because we're too scared to say when
we're done the drug war is a disaster
and yet it goes on forever the
afghanistan war was our longest and we
ended up worse off than we started
thanks joe
and we now have bureaucrats who keep
moving our coveted goalposts based on a
refusal to accept any risk no matter how
low it is meanwhile we chip away at our
freedoms under an authoritarian state
where citizens are deputized to knock on
each other which enables the war to
continue and allows the people in power
to keep flexing like their chris cuomo
on chess day
and the war machine is now the pharma
machine follow the money and you see
that declaring victory hurts a lot of
bottom lines which is why i'm going to
austria for a few weeks if anything to
lend a helping hand everything for the
war effort
let's welcome tonight's yes
this bear never hibernates when it comes
to breaking the news hostess special
reported chief political
bear
i hope doing this show won't ruin his
chances for re-election republican ohio
congressman and author of the new book
do what you said you would do
jim jordan
mention one more southern stereotype and
she'll drown you in a bucket of gravy
and sweet tea fox business anchor
tagging mcdowell
[Music]
and she watched old yeller and rooted
for rabies fox's contributor captain
all right first brett let's get past the
awkward part uh did uh anything convince
you i'm just uh messaging my booking
producers to
see if we have anything open for cat oh
crap there you go well we'll see if we
can make this happen yeah that's so good
because i'm so good-looking and funny um
i think you'll forget about how smart i
am too exactly i mean that's why we have
bill mcgiren on yeah you know so
i want to say one thing i'm going to say
one thing
i came on the last time yes and i went
down to florida and all these people
came up to me and said wow you are on
gutfelt
i loved you on gutfelt and i said you
know i have this show
it's called special report i don't know
if you've seen it
so you're breaking through yeah you know
what it is you just need to add an
exclamation point to special report
exactly just right there and you know do
you want to talk about the topic or if
we
you don't care about covet anymore it's
you've you've moved on i've moved on yes
you know it's serious but i feel like
people are getting to the point where
they're ready to move on don't you i
think so but i hope so but the fact is
they as long as they keep chasing risk
as it gets tinier and tighter we're
never going to change right that's my
fear remember we started with you know
flatten the curve yes prevent the
hospitals from overrunning
now we are we have to eradicate covid so
um it's very serious and people have
lost lives and and families are affected
but as we get over time i think the
country is going to come to a place
where we're going to deal with this long
term yeah congressman welcome to the
show first time everything okay
yes good good good you're not having
second thoughts i had second thoughts
more before i even walked out here
then that's normal normal the one thing
about when when you put something on a
war effort
then you're either
part of the war effort or you're not and
that's what i feel like is happening now
that like if you're not gung-ho about a
vaccine mandate they treat you like
you're an anti-war radical uh when
you're just a normal person like the
folks i get to represent in the fourth
district of ohio they're we're way past
it as well you know we had a i had a guy
who runs a trucking company called me
last week he said half of my 600
employees half of my drivers are not
vaccinated so think what that's going to
mean not just the liberty question but
what it's going to mean in practical
consequences of not having truckers you
think that the ships are backed up now
yeah wait wait till you lose half your
driver so uh this is serious and what
was the the line someone said you know
the hardest part of 15 days to slow this
spread is always the first 18 months so
yeah it's like this this is where we're
at so it's it's scary um
and what they've done to our first
amendment liberties over the last year
frightens me that's
more than all the crazy things we see
from the bite administration that's what
scares me the most and what scares me
about that degan is that it's not being
done by the government it's being
encouraged by the government into
private businesses and private citizens
to become their own narcs that's what
scares me is because that's how
east germany east germany was able to
survive longer than it should in ussr is
that you get the citizens against
citizens well and only when people are
very frightened and and scared
and afraid is when they freely hand over
their civil liberties and freely hand
over their most cherished freedoms is
when they and this is why no offense
these grifters get into this business in
the first place it's for power and
control so you give up those freedoms
that is more control and power in the
hands of washington so what they're
trying to do now is pit the un the
vaccinated against the unvaccinated to
kind of pull start that fear machine to
keep people in a frenzy listen i don't
think one we're all sick of hanging out
with each other cat's gotten a
restraining order out against me because
i was holed up in her house for well
most of most of hope so she's sick of me
number one and i don't think most
americans like being told what to do
yeah i don't don't you know don't wear
those white vinyl boots to church hope
doing it anyway yes
except that there's a part
there's a kind of citizen that likes
telling people what to do we know we
have neighbors like that right i live by
the way i lived in her uh in her inside
her walls during covet what you were
there no yes
that was the smell yes exactly i thought
it was like a dead possum that was a
call back to the movie bad mom but those
people are getting sidelines yes because
people are sick of not well i'm sick of
having an acne face like i've been in a
cherry pie eating contest
like a ring around my mouth it's not
what you think
um
but
no again don't tell me what to do don't
tell me not to
date you know pig pen jesus with no
shoes on who likes to you know eat with
his feet for fun yeah don't tell me that
because i'm going to do that
pigpen jesus he sounds hot to me that's
quite a nickname cat have you dated a
pigpen jesus a few yeah
some of them had tattoos yes yes yes
what about this war analogy is it is it
uh you know comparing it to like the
drug war yeah it never ends yes because
it's another thing that's in common with
that is the facts don't really matter in
this new york times article they're
talking about the threshold set by the
cdc of you know what is you know
qualifies as low transmission or
lulenburg cases like there's only a few
cities where that that exists and like
for examples you know new york city san
francisco dallas it's like what does
the rules in new york city have in
common with the rules in dallas nothing
so you should read that and say okay we
can be done with all these you know
mandates vaccine mandates mask mandates
but they won't do that and they should
and again the people who say follow the
science the sentence stops there show me
some science
exactly i will say overseas they've had
another wave right yeah and so it's
scary when people see that and there are
families that are affected so the
vaccines work but the mandates are the
real question yes i agreed i'm
vaccinated but i'm an anti-mandate for
your request today cdc is out and says
no one who got coveted and recovered has
passed it on to anyone else where's that
science they don't account for the
natural immunity that's the part that
troubles i think so many of us is that
can i have like tongue kiss people now
strangers yes you can if i had covered
like i'm not giving it to you huh yeah
yes but now they're gonna now they're
pushing for like a uh they want a
booster shot every three or four months
now if uh and that's and and when is
that gonna become mandatory i don't know
i'd use the phrase slippery slope but i
banned it hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else